hey you guys I'm Brian right and Alyssa
be crazy we're gonna watch this trailer
today for a little movie called top 5 I
believe it's called top 5 yes it's a
Chris Rock Kevin Hart comedy sounds
interesting I love Kevin Hart a lot I've
seen all of the specials yeah he's
hilarious
oh man if I could be a black guy it
would be Denzel Washington I have no
desire to be Kevin Hart but Denzel I
would I would choose that if we're on
the topic of black people okay apologies
Sirius hits one little stank on it nice
and funny first take was good in 2005
Time magazine voted today's guest the
funniest man in America by 2010 the
former stand-up hit it big with hammy
the bear one two and three I also see
him getting married to reality star
Erica wall there's no camera no
interview I just want a decent story you
give me a couple of really honest things
I will be more than fair this is Chelsea
Brown she's doing a story on me
snitch it come to me baby girl I'm gonna
turn over like a aqua clock you know
what you just ate an apple pie you fat
things are changing you need to wake up
with no pause I'm using the change I
think saving us black man get a cab in
New York City
do you think the wedding is hurting me
are you kidding me Andre this thing
flaps because we talking Dancing with
the Stars what everyone say Landers in
the conference room
we're live in the company's white people
tell me why don't you just skip that hat
questions and go right to something good
all right how come you're not funny
anymore
everybody's funnier smoke it was the
Oprah talks she's hysterical
it's my town anything you need brother
no we serve a lot of time I wasn't into
the wedding I should have been into the
guy as used to be into the girl
I need some wood they got that's great
that looks fantastic I know Chris Rock
hasn't written directed a movie
I think Italy directed one other movie
but something about like I think I love
my wife I think it's what's called this
looks like a really interest it's kind
of like a documentary a black version of
funny people I have no idea what you're
talking about
you haven't seen funny people yeah well
it's about a comedian who doesn't feel
like he's funny anymore he's really in
the spotlight a lot and stuff and he's
trying to like figure out his life I
like the whole execution of it all you
know it's cool to see like I feel like
this is gonna sound like weird or
judgmental but there's a lot of great
black actors in it yeah there's like a
lot of wonderful african-american actors
is it racist to say black I'm the same
black this whole time now I'm
questioning whether or not issues at
black well there's a lot of good black
actors in this movie because it does
look like a community you feel like
anything sees that race no but you got
like you got Cedric in there you got
Whoopi Goldberg and then you got Kevin
Hart and then you know Chris Rock
phenomenal great actors but to have them
all like in this one movie and it's like
I feel like you are gonna get an insight
into like the Chris Rock world II yeah
you know here's what I observed about
watching the trailer is that all the
actors that were chosen that were shown
in the trailer they seemed to bounce off
each other really really well and it
shows it's more personal which i think
is going to be awesome
yeah fun to watch I'm sure there'll be
some drama in it but it doesn't look
like a dramedy you know like a lot of
these movies will tend to be like it's
about a comedian but it's really a
serious movie yeah
it looks like a serious topic but it's a
light-hearted approach to a serious
issue yeah it looks like it's still
gonna be mainly fun at the end of the
day oh you got rosario dawson who's
gorgeous and Gabrielle Union one of my
favorite black actresses I can I just
say actress things kind of send myself
up so yeah hey you really you don't know
I feel like an idiot I think about like
people are gonna be like do you ever say
that's my favorite white actresses I'm
like and we'll know because most
actresses in America are white people
that are like really touchy about it and
there are other people that like try to
make it an issue when it's like not
meant to be an issue you know and what
do you mean by people do you mean black
people those people in general like you
know just people in general I'm trying
to put the hate on you sorry I wanted to
divert well if you guys are new to the
channel and if you're black you can
subscribe to the real rejects and the
last site ELISA likes black people too
you can subscribe to ELISA be crazy
Michael McCormack
please give me a shout out please
Michael McCormack you did not give me
anything to work off here so there's
gonna be a very short shout out shout
out to you McCormick McCormick has a big
dick he's a little prick he has a best
friend named Nick sometimes Nick chugs
on his dick and it gets Nick a little
bit sick but what happens when Nick
gives it a little Lickety lick he's
gonna come through him like John wick is
my stick yeah I have a friend named Rick
little mar 22
that's what I call what's your nickname
for my penis photos the rock there's a
lot of nicknames for my penis the Paul
Rudd yeah you know a little March 22 in
the 22 because this is the 22nd pair of
balls I've had to try on to produce just
the right amount of sperm because I had
a issue where every balls I got would
produce too much sperm is there I didn't
know there was a store for that is there
like no it's a very underground surgery
place $500,000 per ball I have spent
like 40 million dollars on my testicles
do you have it like a secret job I don't
know about what is it honey yeah Ralph's
comes with great benefits huh there you
go a little more 22 you're named after
my penis and balls that's what your
parents did zr9 Jack Daniels Ryan my
friend Andy watches your vids from time
to time and I told them if you wanted to
be mentioned in one of your videos so
just comment and ask for a shout-out but
it doesn't think that will work so he
hasn't even tried oh look here's the
thing if you don't try you have zero
percent of a chance of having it shout
it out
if you try at least once you have a
higher percentage of shout outage if you
want something be don't try you have
already failed life lessons but then
there's more yes so if you can give him
one that would be great and I cannot
wait to see his reaction so hopefully
don't take forever to get to him hehe
thanks man
Andy dude don't be shy ma'am it's like
what Alyssa and I were just telling you
you never know unless you try you want
to know how I get girls Wow and this is
exactly the same method you seen before
I say hey I have a friend named little
Mar 22 what you like to meet a little
mar 22 and then I just show them a
little more 22 there you go 9 times out
of 10 it will not work but look at
veronika number 10 that's what I got 1
out of 10 I don't think that's how it
works law of averages and then before
you know it you do it then